this is a good class this workshop
signals new beginnings for every person
in this room the standards that we're
talking about
we are not going to compromise anymore
in our lives
that's over no more if i would or could
or should
hope for prisoners works with men and
women helping them successfully
transition to life
outside of prison walls you have to have
support and the first number one
support comes from family and then you
have to have the support of community
john ponder the hope for a prisoner's
founder was once there
in and out of prison for years he
finally got it right
and created the group in 2009 to give
others the support
he didn't have i speak from my own
personal experience
when you're dealing with people from
this second of the population
the majority of people they really want
to change they have no idea how to do it
hfp has partnered with vegas chamber
deter and workforce connections to host
a virtual job fair
on april 22nd it is truly life-changing
for them
when they see that there's an
opportunity for them and great
opportunities
now they become some of the best
employees inside the workplace because
they're extremely appreciative
at that opportunity they really want to
be able to take advantage of it
hfp has hundreds of success stories
ranging from people continuing their
education
rising through the ranks on their job
and becoming managers to reuniting
families
employers are really looking for a
dedicated strong workforce
and i couldn't think of any other better
population than the folks that we're
working with that are
really looking forward to going to work
and excited at the opportunities that
are before them
bianca holman 8 news now